bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans les 7 8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
basket féminin le chesnay-versailles
n'en finit plus de gagner en nationale 2
les yvelinoises ont remporté une
précieuse victoire ce week-end composent
stade français 53 50 un score qui leur
permet de devenir co-leader du
championnat plus d'informations à suivre
course à pied la 4ème édition de la
course royal était organisée entre la
pièce d'eau des suisses à versailles le
gymnase descartes de fontenay-le-fleury
plus de 800 personnes se sont inscrites
pour l'événement box grosse déception
pour la trappiste gallus coulon le
boxeur de la tille farruggia il encourt
s'est incliné aux points face à massy
tâche au fonds nous recevons le sportif
dans quelques instants sur ce plateau
pour débriefer cette contre performance
group prend à présent sur les principaux
résultats du week-end
un début de saison un canon pour
l'entente le chesnay versailles en
nationale 2 féminine de basket les
joueuses de vinko berdych ont enregistré
leur cinquième victoire de la saison sur
leur parquet contre stade français une
victoire acquise dans les dernières
secondes 53 à 50 conséquence les
héninoises deviennent co leader du
championnat les images ont signé à
nicholas bray
le chesnay-versailles remporté le choc
de cette sixième journée de nationale 2
le fcv 78 qui pointait à la 3e place du
classement avant la rencontre a dominé
le cinquième le stade français sur son
parquet au gymnase bel air le score 53 à
50 je pense que on gagne cette star
parce qu'on a bien joué en défense
c'était un match c'était un match
important pour nous parce que c'est un
c'était un derby et je pense qu'on
mérite ce soir 2
de gagner le match seul bémol la fin de
match du chesnay versailles à pouces 7 à
3 minutes 40 du terme les yvelinoises
ont pas réussi à conserver leur avance
et se sont fait peur jusqu'à la dernière
seconde on a perdu énormément de ballons
et ça bah ça peut coûter cher et on le
voit en fin de match on aurait pu le
tuer avec les lancers francs déjà mais
si on perd pas des ballons on leur donne
pas cette possibilité de revenir et ça
on n'a pas su faire donc on aurait pu se
rendre à cash plus facile sans les
pertes de balle
au classement les joueuses devimco
bardigues réalise un début de saison
surprenant pour un promu avec cinq
victoires et une défaite un bilan qui
permet aux yvelinoise de partager le
fauteuil de leader avec saint paul hervo
on s'attendait pas forcément à ça parce
que ce serait vraiment prétentieux note
pas en montant de nationale 3 on
assurait deux tout de suite dire bah on
a les capacités d'être au tableau nous
notre objectif c'est d'abord le maintien
on prend les matches les uns après les
autres après manon crache pas sur les
victoires on est à 5 1 on est très
content d'avoir gagné ce mur le stade
français qui sont potentiellement des
grosses équipes autre point positif de
cette soirée le chesnay versailles reste
invaincu à domicile le gymnase bel air
est devenue une forteresse imprenable
une citadelle qu'il faudra à nouveau
défendre ce samedi 12 novembre à 20
heures les yvelinoises reçoivent allant
sonner sixième du classement
on ouvre à présent une page running
c'est désormais une tradition dans les
yvelines pour la quatrième année
consécutive la course royal était
organisée ce dimanche matin entre
versailles et fontenay-le-fleury
l'événement réunit cette année plus de
800 participants venus de toute l'île de
france le montage est signée xavier
gélin
dimanche 6 novembre de 9 heures 45 le
départ de la quatrième édition de la
course royal entre versailles et
fontenay le fleury sera donné dans
quelques minutes par les organisateurs à
la pièce d'eau des suisses pour réaliser
le meilleur chrono possible et 800
participants inscrits ont tous une
stratégie
peux pas écouter au feeling je vous
rajoute suivre le parcours et puis je me
suis entraînée par la foule et si ça
doit difficile sur la fin mais je ne
vais serrer les dents tout simplement
personnellement moi j'ai légère à un
niveau de tranquille entre 11 12 km
heure tranquille je sais qu'ils y
aillent à la mres c'est vraiment un
grand moment pour moi celui qui avait la
bonne formule sur ce 10 km c'est lui à
bezons azzedine remporté la compétition
pour la deuxième fois consécutive en 32
minutes et 34 secondes avec près de
trois minutes d'avancé sur le second dan
kelly gadea quand je suis venu je suis
venu pour gagner c'est pas pour moi
ouais comme c'est c'est moi qui a gagné
l'année dernière
on est un peu sur le 20 km jérôme tassin
originaire de saint rémy les chevreuse
s'est imposé en une heure 12 minutes et
46 secondes c'est la première fois que
je savais pas qu'ils étaient les
adversaires donc voilà je suis parti
dans un petit groupe et qu'après au
troisième trimestre du parti au
troisième kilomètre j'ai pris les
commandes du 20 km et après j'ai pu
lâcher donc voilà apprécié que
logiquement je savais que de garder le
rythme
chez les filles pas de record la
première féminine termine le 10 km aux
quarante et une minutes et 24 secondes
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour la
cinquième édition de la course 3 yann
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'accueille
pas que des compétitions internationales
le temple du cyclisme sur piste français
reçoit également des événements aux
régionaux ce dimanche le grand prix de
vélizy était organisé par le club local
retour sur la compétition des images de
nicolas landry
le grand prix de vélizy fêté ce dimanche
sa troisième édition lancée en 2014
l'événement organisé par l'équipe
cycliste vélizy 78 est intégré à la
coupe d'île de france au programme de
l'omnium du keirin du scratch de la
vitesse et des courses aux points notre
vocation bien sûr c'est de permettre aux
coureurs régionaux de s'exprimer sur ce
magnifique vélodrome la vocation donc
c'est de permettre à des jeunes de
découvrir cette magnifique piste et
pourquoi pas
de découvrir le champion de demain cette
année 125 fois revenue de 10 régions se
sont inscrits pour participer à
l'événement j'ai pu faire plaisir et
qu'on a la chance d'avoir
au vélodrome de france à saint quentin
donc
quand il ya des courses on vient on en
profite
même si je suis pas au mieux de ma forme
ça fait plaisir de courir c'est juste
exceptionnel de venir sera sur le droit
national pouvoir courir comme le
professionnel un plateau qui a séduit le
public ils étaient plus de 500
spectateurs dans les tribunes pour
assister à l'événement je trouve ça
convivial et très intéressant
peut être qui sait mes enfants
[Musique]
c'est un peu la vocation de ce genre
d'épreuve c'est de faire venir du public
public sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines pour justement
fidéliser après vélizy le vélo-club de
montigny-le-bretonneux organisera la
seconde manche de la coupe de france le
11 décembre prochain toujours au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
au niveau des résultats marine cloarec
de meaux a terminé à la première place
sur le keirin l'omnium cades et à lui
été remporté par clément petit d'evreux
qu une page boxe dans ce magazine à
finale de la catégorie à mi moyens entre
le trappistes gallus coulon et massy
tâchons de fontenay sous bois a tourné à
l avantage de ce dernier le saint
quentinois s'est incliné aux points à la
fin du huitième ronde pour parler de ce
combat nous recensons justement sur ce
plateau al ghad us coulon bonjour
françois rial us alors j'imagine qu'il
ya une très grande frustration après ce
combat énorme déception parce que
j'étais aux portes pour moi les
championnats de france j'étais vraiment
aux portes il fallait que je valide ce
combat pour pouvoir prétendre à la
marche bleue au dessus donc maintenant
ça s'est pas concrétisée comme j'aurais
voulu mais voilà je vais relativise en
me disant que c'est le sport vous avez
fait peut-être des erreurs stratégiques
sur ce combat stratégie que je pense
qu'au niveau du combat au niveau du
combat j'ai été le plus précis sur le
haut sur la globalité du combat plus
précis quand il y avait des moments de
remous jeu marqué des points avec mon
brave en maintenant dans la finalité du
des juges s'il a semblé que apparemment
ce bilan n'a pas été
aussant si tel comme tel par les juges
donc voilà maintenant c'est une grosse
déception et falloir réfléchir pour la
suite et pour repartiez pour pouvoir
repartir quoi vous avez perdu beaucoup
de combat au niveau de l'arbitrage
comment l'expliquez vous cette fois
cette fois ci encore il ya il y a une
petite on va dire
appréhensions sur sur le sur le score
c'est toujours un peu litigieux quand on
combat commandant combat de boxe on te
dit que tu perds 2 1 ou 2 points voilà
ta à l'extérieur c'est toujours un peu
douteux maintenant je vais pas me cacher
derrière ça peut-être que je n'ai pas
été assez méchant peut-être pas assez
rageux de la voir là c'est la rage pour
pouvoir y aller plus je sais pas
maintenant on peut toujours se ressasser
le combat une fois deux fois trois fois
c'est maintenant le les dés ont été
jetés donc maintenant c'est vraiment
enfin je me remette vraiment en question
parce que
physiquement voilà même à 26 ans je sais
pas finir à 26 ans physiquement je suis
encore au top
voilà encore des performances qui montre
que voilà c'est encore loin de la fin
mais voilà sur les prochains combats
falloir vraiment réfléchir sur les
adversaires
pour pouvoir remonter dans le positif
parce que
vraiment le palmarès ne reflète pas du
tout la personne que je suis et voilà
c'est qu'en boxe avec serveur c'est
comme ça faut il faut ces dossiers c'est
drôle à dire mais c'est à l'extérieur
c'est le cas où voilà c'est ça passe pas
et est ce que vous regrettez des votre
préparation
insuffisante la préparation a été
clément je ne veux pas me cacher
derrière ma préparation non ma
préparation était vraiment complète j'ai
mis les gants avec des adversaires
classés niveau européen non vraiment
j'ai émises de guara été très très bien
j'étais même parfois au dessus non
vraiment la préparation était complète
tu peux pas me cacher derrière ça et
dire que la corée préparation n'ont
vraiment c'était si je pense que j'ai
même dû jamais été aussi bien préparé
c'est c'est dommage à le dire puisque la
vie le corps n'est pas là finalement
mais non j'ai de la préparation était
vraiment au top vous visez une revanche
face à massy tâches ou revanche ça va
dépendre de plein de facteurs revanche
je n'étais pas là maintenant les
objectifs avec tanguy en a discuté donc
il faut déjà qu'ils vont alors voilà
c'est ça tanguait farruggia ça va être
déjà dans un premier temps
on va discuter pour un changement de
catégorie donc passer à la catégorie en
dessous en super légers qui correspond à
63 500 car actuellement je vois que ça
66 678 g exactement donc passer à la
catégorie su après avec mes capacités
physiques
magnum à ma taille et cetera je pense
que on pense qu'il ya quelque chose à
faire - dana question lovisi un titre de
champion de france juste avant ce combat
c'est encore votre objectif encore
aujourd'hui je suis un acharné vraiment
je suis un acharné physiquement comme je
l'aï dit précédemment je suis encore au
top
jadis physiques qui sont vraiment
vraiment superbe donc ouais c'est
toujours un objectif ouais c'est
toujours un objectif maintenant va
falloir vraiment faire les bons choix au
niveau des adversaires au niveau des
combats à venir pour pouvoir repassé
dans le positif et pouvoir prétendre à
cette ceinture nationale qui me tient
vraiment à coeur merci beaucoup gallus
coulon bon courage pour la suite de
votre carrière en tout cas intervenir à
vous suivre sur tv fil 78 on prend à
présent à la direction de l'océan
atlantique ce dimanche 6 novembre à
13h02 exactement vote neuf skippers se
sont élancés des sables d'olonne pour
participer au mythique vendée globe 2016
pour cette huitième édition de ce tour
du monde en solitaire et sans escale
plus de trois cent cinquante mille
personnes se sont rassemblées pour
encourager ces sportifs de l'extrême
dans la flotte en poète apercevoir
troisi me noie le verset éric bellion
aborde son imoca comme un seul homme
laurent polito louis burton sur bureau
vallée tanguy de lamotte originaire de
versailles à lui a pris le large avec
son initiative coeur on écoute justement
un livre in white enregistré une vidéo
pour ses fans
la première vidéo du vendée globe est un
super départ je voulais vraiment
remercier de tout coeur l'orchestration
de la partie car
c'est vraiment une bonne idée
à 15h le verset et tanguy de lamotte
pointait à la 11e place louis burton sur
bureau vallée suit juste derrière à la
14e place éric bellion pour sa première
participation est pour l'instant 25e la
course est dominé par le skipper d'hugo
boss alex thomson c'est la fin de ce set
8 sport merci d'avoir suivi je vous
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine d'ici là passez une excellente
semaine sportive
[Musique]